that's what they're waiting for they're
waiting for one race you know we've
endorsed dr oz we've endorsed
jp right j.d mandel
and he's doing great because at one time
science said man came from aids right
did it no
i really didn't when you go to it every
time i read or hear that i think to
myself you just didn't read the same
bible i did well this was interesting
though if that is true
why are there still apes
think about it you know now you're
getting too smart for it no no no no
think about this we have an evolution
that is we've gotten so intelligent that
if that is true why are they still late
but it doesn't grocery shopping i'm at
wagner's and uh my wife wants some
vegetables for crudites right so
here's a broccoli that's two bucks not a
ton of broccoli there there's some
asparagus that's four dollars yep
carrots
that's four more dollars there's ten
dollars of vegetables there and then we
need some guacamole that's four dollars
more
and
she loves salsa yeah salsa there
six dollars
must be a shortage of salsa guys that's
twenty dollars for kuru te this doesn't
include the tequila i mean that's
outrageous we got joe biden to thank for
this we're in a war with bureaucrats
that have forced vaccine mandates on us
masked mandates on us and you know what
they're pushing this wokeness confusion
down our throats now and by the way we
should try anthony fauci and put him in
front of a firing squad don't i do
you've never been in the private sector
all right gentlemen
squatch
uh don't tell me it hasn't worked don't
tell me i haven't watched
[Laughter]
i want to say that we would not even be
in ukraine
if president biden did not shut down the
keystone pipeline on the first day why
because
now that that's shut down we have to get
our oil and we're getting it from russia
and we're getting
all these problems through the ukraine
and that's not why they went into
ukraine ukraine they went into ukraine
because ukraine didn't want to be part
of nato listen you're trying to be
you're trying to work on the national
stage and you don't even know why the
war started in ukraine it had nothing to
do with the keystone pipeline the
keystone pipeline caused the the
inflation and the increase in our gas
prices i went in to ukraine is because
russia
wanted ukraine as they had him pre-world
war ii and ukraine wanted to be part of
nato respond please
he's right i made a mistake
so if you're only listening today and
not watching she's in one of these kind
of like indoor outdoor or outdoor indoor
things she's walking around
um
she's
you know knocking on the outdoor indoor
kind of tent type thing that is going on
there um and she uh she has covered
people want to ask me all the time while
i'm running i'm sick and tired i'm sick
and tired of them want to
teach ctr in
school it's a dc game
[Music]
well if it isn't big jim lane we're
tired of being pushed around and open
borders and gas prices the good people
of arizona have had enough of you
it's time for a showdown
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm jim layman and i approve this
message you were observed going 57 and a
40 and you were on your phone texting
while you were doing that can i see you
like exactly yes sir i do you are going
to be assured a citation for texting and
driving
okay
you are going to be a citation
for
texting and driving
one thing that i've been doing is
praying that if anyone tries to steal a
vote that god would send the angels to
steal the vote back to make it an honest
vote yeah i think we might as well ask i
mean the angels are you know they can do
things they can do jobs i have strong
core christian conservative values and i
want to emphasize one word and they're
christian it's my faith that brought me
into this race and it's my faith that
will lead me when i go to congress to
fight some of the woke
transgender you name it um
agenda that they have they're trying to
force on us do you support any new gun
laws in the wake of this texas shooting
do you support new gun laws in the wake
of what i like to do but i like doing
[ __ ] and uh and everything and stuff i
like to see it you know
will you concede that the first
amendment only applies to government
like twitter has nothing that twitter's
not governed by the first amendment i
hear you saying maybe you would like it
to be but do you agree that as far as
the law is today twitter and the first
amendment are not intertwined in any way
i would say that
i'm not i wouldn't be prepared to answer
that now in the manner which i would
like i'd like to look into things a
little bit more
who's the current president of the
united states
who's the current president well
i guess um i guess it's a it's a funny
it's a funny question is it really
yeah i do think it we live in a very
interesting time
where
um
we have there's forces beyond our
visibility who's the current president
well
i don't believe that uh the current
president is a is a legitimate president
and we'll leave it at that is joe biden
currently the president even if you
think he's illegitimate is he the
president
i don't believe he is i don't believe
that is the current legitimate president
and who is the current legitimate
president
um
i don't i don't believe we have a
current legitimate president